because of the specific excellences of
our commencement speaker I can answer
that question and introduce him at the
same time mark halperin is a novelist
an essayist a journalist an analyst and
an editorialist he is educated at
Harvard at Oxford at Princeton at
Columbia his father and his mother were
both involved in entertainment his
father did secret things for a good
cause in World War two his novels and
his short stories are beautiful by that
term I mean that they reflect in their
composition and also in their meaning
the best and highest things the things
we love the most the things that brought
these students here and brought you here
to celebrate them his war stories are
full of love his love stories are full
of struggle when he writes for the
public prints sometimes it's analytical
ly almost like a catalog sometimes it's
always powerful sometimes when the
subject matter and the condition of
things admits of it it's inspiring and
beautiful I happen to have known him for
many years and regard him is one of the
best people I know my favorite book of
his is called a soldier of the great war
it is a story of war and of love the
soldier loves his life the war threatens
his life he loves his life because of a
special way that people are located in
nature just like any dog or cat or hit
or pig they know the joys and the pains
of existence but they make choices about
them and so they cooperate with nature
in the making of their lives and when
they have the joys and they know that
the joys are justified then a sense of
beauty comes over them
and they have a communion with the
things above and they can be terrified
often especially in war but war reminds
them of the preciousness of this in this
book the love of the soldier is
distilled into the love of a woman the
war takes the woman from him will he get
her back you must read the book to see
if he gets her back but I can tell you
that when you discover the answer to
that you will weep for is an
intensification of life of the dangers
and the choices it gives us it is there
to take our life but also it shows us
life it's important that Mark Halperin
was the first choice of the senior class
officers they know his work something
about them I'm proud to say also
something about their education made
them want him to come and speak to them
on this day so important to them why
would that happen here what was the
college that lately had a commencement
address delivered over television by a
convicted murderer on death row will
there not be proceeding all over the
nation today commitments commencements
in which the speaker cast doubt upon
everything we have always called good
even up to the relation between parents
and children where this happens the
colleges have lost the ability to look
up in the name of the politically
correct causes they've lost the idea of
goodness and of truth and a beauty and
if one loses those ideas it is not long
until he will lose his freedom
we here at Hillsdale College regard
ourselves as fighters for freedom and
that is because we are seekers and
lovers of truth and goodness and beauty
I have never before stated what I think
is the meaning of our college at the
same time as I introduced a commencement
speaker but this commencement speaker
makes that easy to do please welcome a
warrior poet Mark Halperin
thank you
are you disappointed that I'm not
Charlie Sheen I'm not president Arn
mrs. Arn chairman broad Beck congressman
Roskam professor Whelan professor Jordan
mr. cha Feeny Colonel sussing ham
distinguished faculty trustees alumni
guests graduates and not least families
as you are not only what makes all this
possible but to borrow a phrase from the
Second World War that for which we fight
it is my privilege to speak to you today
in this College
we're since before the Civil War the
transcendent ideals of the Republic have
been upheld in the face of opposition
from argument to bullets weds to the
proposition that all men are created
equal Hillsdale students in
extraordinary numbers fought and died to
preserve the Union and to free the
slaves who they knew were equal before
God and is treasured by him as any
people in his creation and they still
know this they still uphold it
colorblind as they uphold by and large
the principles of government that
derives its just powers from the consent
of the governed of the individuals
carefully calibrated responsibilities to
society and of society's debt and
deference to the individual a phrase you
do not often hear in these times this
takes some courage but just recognition
will come as it does as it must to those
who although they may hope for the
approval of men appeal to the judgment
of heaven
and therefore fight on all around this
campus which is lovely especially in May
when you can see it and there are no
walls you will see statues of exemplary
statesmen and of Margaret Thatcher who
is also a statesman the route is the
same but she is also as we know a woman
I'm going to depart from my text for a
moment to tell you an apocryphal story
about her undoubtedly apocryphal you
know that she dominated her cabinet like
a lioness her all-male cabinet they were
quite obedient to her and the story goes
that one day she took them for dinner at
the Connaught they all trooped around
the table and sat down she sat at the
head the waiter brought the menu she
looked at it and said in her decisive
way I'll have the steak the waiter said
what about the vegetables and she said
they'll have the same
I don't believe that it happened but it
does express the truth
among these statues of course is that of
Winston Churchill and what follows an
exercise in the imagination is to
consider what it would be like to be
blessed with someone of Churchill's
quality to fit the challenges of our
times lest the great but now silent man
be Kressley appropriated by even a cause
he would embrace the guardians of his
legacy rightly caution against
speculation of the type I think you've
heard it that would go something like
this if Alexander the Great were alive
he most likely would have voted for the
Clean Water Act or if Oliver Twist were
here he certainly would have approved
and No Child Left Behind would he have
had a choice one cannot know for sure
what Churchill would do in a given
situation but as he is nothing if not
the paradigm of statesmanship does this
mean that when we are in need we cannot
consult the lives of leaders of rare
genius should we ask instead what Jimmy
Carter would do what Joe Biden or
therefore Neil Kinnock as our vice
president is famous for plagiarizing the
former leader of the British Labour
Party would do or Barney Frank possibly
not not to risk projection and
imagination and statesmanship would be
to lack the kind of courage for which
Churchill was noted and to which he came
at an early age understanding that we
have but one life and that for those who
enter at the point of the spear each day
into the uncharted territory of decision
audacity not only sweetens life but
preserves it as nothing else so let us
touch upon just five of the many
Churchill Ian characteristics to which
our contemporaries in public service
rarely aspire much less achieved in
regard to language experience solvency
justice and valour you might start off
thinking that he was purely English but
soon would discover that he was also
American
and better yet that elementally there is
little difference between the two having
come from the same fuse possessing the
same root even if the separate branches
have their own form for they are bound
in the same wood and by the same
mystical power which is the English
language which was Churchill's
inspiration and his power to inspire his
means of decision his comfort his shield
and his sword beyond the capacity of
analysis the English language holds
within it all the waters that refresh
the tree of liberty and they are in
their various streams honor equality
probity courage and humility without
which no nation no matter its luck or
gifts can admirably survive or is worthy
to more powerful than armies though not
in the least
obviating them it carries within it the
rhythms and balances of strategic genius
lucky for Britain and the rest of us
that Winston Spencer Churchill carried
within him the neverending arsenal
perfected by Shakespeare Milton Gibbon
Johnson and Carlisle and by every
graceful graceful but forgotten speaker
in Parliament or before the bar or upon
a field gleaming in the Sun in the depth
of a mine or at the rail of a ship we
have such speakers to all across the
land in little towns like this and in
the towers of the great cities but our
presidents of late have failed to
discover that substance cannot be
decoupled from style that it is almost a
divine law that in the winds of
narcissism and dishonesty the cells of
rhetoric deflate put simply you cannot
draw upon the glory of the English
language
if nearly every utterance is a lie by
the time he first became Prime Minister
Churchill was 65 years old he had seen
war all over the world
including at an advanced age in the
trenches of the Great War he had been
both prisoner and escapee of the Boers
a member of parliament for almost 40
years Undersecretary of State for the
colonies President of the Board of Trade
Home Secretary
First Lord of the Admiralty twice which
carried two mathematical absurdity would
have made him second Lord of the
Admiralty minister of munitions
Secretary of State for war Minister of
Air Secretary of State for the colonies
and Chancellor of the Exchequer he would
be Minister of Defence twice and Prime
Minister yet again technically twice
more he had spent many years in the
political wilderness struggling against
the common wisdom of disarmament and
appeasement he had become a good painter
and a competent bricklayer raised a
family and lost the child
her name was marigold and she was very
small and he had risked everything in a
certifiably insane pursuit of making
one's living as a writer producing not
only hundreds of penetrating articles
but many books including two great
historical studies one of which
Marlborough Leo Strauss called the
greatest historical work in our century
his subsequent study of the Second World
War would win the Nobel Prize and this
does not touch upon his inner
development his skill at horsemanship
his wit erudition strength character
bravery and pure genius which were in
constant ferment and overwhelmingly
abundant even though he who had done
more than anyone else to save
civilization considered himself in the
1930s and just before his death a
failure as indeed he became when his
daughter took her own life compared such
a man if you will to a nightmare person
like Donald Trump
work to the ill-formed adolescent
presidents of recent decades it is not
so much the resume resumes or pieces of
paper that flutter into the grave but
the gravitas that we lack in our leaders
in a nation of more than 300 million
where are the adults where are those who
will invite and can withstand what
Churchill called continual stress of
soul where are those with enough
experience in the world not to be
hypnotized by self regard is it now a
law of nature that such people cannot
get within a hundred miles of the
presidency and whose fault is that if
not our own
Churchill was merely against President
Roosevelt's plan to reduce Germany to a
pastoral state but he would have been
astounded by so many Americans so
hostile to industry and economic growth
that they would do this to their own
country we must and can remain an
industrial technological leading
confident nation in the 70s we were
confronted and we are still confronted
with cheap labor overseas and flooding
across our border and in the 70s we
failed and we fail still to meet this
challenge with automation innovation and
sovereign assertion in response that at
one time would have been as natural as
the rain or breathing and for which as
the technological leaders of the world
we were fully prepared this is still
open to us but we do not have a Winston
Churchill to urge it nor do we have a
Winston Churchill as once we had a
Ronald Reagan to prefer and defend the
saving principles both practical and as
they relate to self-determination of the
free market the liberation of productive
energies and the fundamental right of
property these are proven and worthy of
constant encouragement nor do we have a
Winston Churchill who although and
because he was often forced to honor
solvency in the breach would tell us
that
there is no saving principle of debt
there is no saving principle of funny
money there is no saving principle of
living beyond one's means and if it is
to succeed if it is to survive a whole
nation cannot live a lie although we
have been admirably trying my question
is when will we find the courage to
break that lie and who will tell us as
Churchill would that in payment for our
hapless decades we will see in the next
blood toil tears and sweat but that we
have withstood and come through these
before and can again strengthened
tranquil quietly proud because it is
written in our history and written in
our blood as a subaltern at Bangalore in
1896 in the British Raj and a hot and
trying son
Churchill read a million words of given
including these the subjects of Rome
were insulted by the arrogance of a
young minister who considered his rapid
elevation as proof of his superior merit
imagine how he might be struck by what
follows which is not a criticism of the
First Lady of the United States however
complicit in the embarrassing
presumption she reveals and who was
nothing more when she said this but an
honest reporter and she said I quote
Barack Obama will require you to work he
is going to demand that you shed your
cynicism that you put down your
divisions that you come out of your
isolation Barack will never allow you to
go back to your lives as usual
uninvolved on
formed I will read this again because I
can never believe it Barack Obama will
require you to work he is going to
demand that you shed your cynicism that
you put down your divisions that you
come out of your isolation Barack will
never allow you to go back to your lives
as usual that's true
uninvolved uninformed I do not think
that Winston Churchill would have
believed that an American president
could so insult his own countrymen or
assume so authoritarian a caste I think
he would have been as appalled as I am
and if mrs. Obama's revelation is
allowed to pass without correction then
this is not the country I know this is
not the country my forebears and yours
crossed the oceans to reach and were
forced and carried across the oceans to
reach and stay to build and died to
defend we have rights in this they are
compelling and they are absolute
Churchill understood that they are the
greatest achievements of civilization as
it has painfully arisen from group
corporate ethnic racial and sectarian
identities from subjugation and from
slavery and that is such the rights and
protections of the individual must not
ever be affronted by officials who
somehow believe that they are the
masters of those whom they serve the
impulse to command the American people
so as to compensate for its supposedly
tainted origins comes from a mistaken
conception of history in which because
of not a few of the founders hypocrisy
in regard to slavery the founding
principles are dismissed
but that hypocrisy was washed away in a
war one not merely due to the industrial
and demographic strength of the north
but because it was fought to affirm
principles slowly discovered in the old
world at immense cost carried to the new
at immense cost perfected at the
founding at immense cost and proved in
the most perilous assertion of our
existence at the cost of more than
600,000 dead to think that the sin of
slavery was attributable to the ideals
of the founding rather than to their
suppression is to think that it is the
oak that chokes the ivy or the daylight
that illuminates the Sun and until this
misconception is overturned justice must
always be afflicted and presidents may
yet presume to instruct Hector and
revolutionize a nation they see as
forever faulted by its original sin a
nation that therefore they do not
understand
I believe that Winston Churchill great
statesman great historian would see this
with the utmost clarity but even Winston
Churchill sometimes departed from the
first principle of statesmanship which
we ourselves have dangerously forgotten
and that he called the paramount
necessity of preparedness no matter what
the material state no matter the balance
sheet and no matter how one's heart may
beat defense of the nation must come
first war abhors
and will rush to exploit a vacuum of
deterrent power and then the cherished
narratives and designs of a nation's
prosperity will instantly and sometimes
forever be displaced with the practical
for the parochial view of the chancellor
of the exchequer
churchill was as responsible as even
Neville Chamberlain for the ten-year
rule writing quote that it should now be
laid down as a standing assumption that
at any given date there will be no major
war for ten years from that date that
rule was as good an answer as any to
john f kennedy's question of why England
slept
but soon after Churchill endorsed it he
was forced to look from the wilderness
upon the whole of things and this is
where greatness found him he would have
been fully alive to our hostile and
chaotic world in which weapons of mass
destruction grant medieval religious
fanatics and pariah States the potential
of great nations and he would have
recognized the consistent harmonious
inevitably rising power of China which
augments its military by leaps and
bounds as by leaps and bounds we
deconstruct our own I cannot believe
that to address the imbalances that are
the temptations to aggression he would
not resume his famous calls for action
without which the cost of lost Wars and
money broken hearts and national
darkness will far exceed any material
sacrifice required to avoid them
now our leaders must be licensed
sensibly can be required and should be
impelled to see the oncoming waves and
move the nation to higher ground this of
course is what Churchill attempted to do
in the wilderness years but who among
our high officials or candidates to
replace them does so now who has
mastered the particulars
who dares affront the common wisdom and
risk reputation livelihood and respect I
hear no names called out for there is no
one and there will be no one until there
is someone someone old enough for
ambition to have flared and died someone
who sees the presidency as a grave and
exhausting task that can responsibly be
met only with the continual stress of
soul of which Churchill spoke someone
like Winston Churchill if I am wrong and
mr. Churchill would not subscribe in
spirit to these things I have said I
would say them still I have said them
and I stand by them because they are
true so when you next hear a candidate
for president and he flatters you and he
tells you that you can have everything
you can't
that you can borrow indefinitely you
can't and that you are safe in the world
you aren't think of Winston Churchill
think of language experience solvency
justice and valor like England if we
rise to the occasion
we too can produce statesmen almost
unique in the world in knowing that they
stand not above their compatriots but
with them for our history is too stained
with blood and tears our principles too
resilient and our talents too many our
landscapes too beautiful and our people
too good for our time just to be over
because your time is just beginning our
time is not over
make it so